Bethesda Softworks was actually offered to
make an official open world Game of Thrones
game in 2011, but turned it down in order
to make Skyrim.
In the early 1900s a group of US government
scientists a private dinner club, in which
they only ate poisonous food.
They documented their illness in order to
convince congress to pass food safety laws.
The were called “The Poison Squad”.
A man named Daniel Balsam got so infuriated
with constant email spam that he quit his
job, got a law degree and has so far earned
over $1 million in court judgements against
the spammers.
Graffiti artist David Choe who painted Facebook's
fist office in 2005 was paid in shares, which
is now worth over $200 million.
13 of the 20 most polluted cities in the world
are in India.
During his Indian campaign, Alexander the
Great encountered a tribe that hadn't discovered
fire yet.
Prostitution exists amongst some penguins
and chimpanzees.
They prostitute themselves for things like
stones or food.
Prince Harry is partial owner of a racehorse
named Usain Colt.
A 10-year psychological study found that men
who kissed their wives before leaving for
work lived, on average, 5 years longer and
earned up to 30 per cent more than peers who
left without a kiss.
Odds are, any memory you believe you have
before the age of 4 isn't real.
They are false memories and have usually either
been told to you by someone else, or you made
them up without knowing it.
Before 2012, the largest buyer of kale in
the US was Pizza Hut and they only used it
as a garnish around their salad bar.
During sleep, fluid in the body tends to pool
in low-lying areas, which is why most of us
wake up with noticeable bags under our eyes.
The average Bugatti customer has about 84
cars, 3 jets and one yacht.
Estonian ID cards have a chip with a public-private
key pair that's used to sign documents and
vote in elections via the internet.
For their 2011 election, 24% of the votes
were cast online.
Barely a year after the 1969 moon landing
the American public had completely lost interest
in space exploration, to such an extent that
90 percent of people could not remember Neil
Armstrong's name.
Octopuses are very intelligent.
In 1875, one octopus at the Brighton Aquarium
would escape from its tank when the guards
weren't looking, eat the lump fish in another
tank, then go back to its own tank before
the aquarium opened.